[Music]
thanks for coming over here you guys
talk to you yes I love the micro biome
got health all that good stuff excited
to explore it with you guys today I
really enjoyed meeting you guys recently
I was super impressed with the work that
you're doing and how steeped and well
versed you are in this confusing terrain
the subject matter that is sort of all
the rage at the moment it's been
interesting to kind of track the
mainstream sort of acceptance and
enthusiasm and interest in micro in the
microbiome and and gut health but I also
think as you know there's a lot of
confusion out there about it especially
when it comes to informing consumer
choices around products that are going
to best serve our gut health so why
don't we start with just defining our
terms a little bit like what is the
microbiome yeah so the microbiome is the
collection of organisms that live in and
on the human body the majority of the
microbial presence in the body is
concentrated in the gut the lower gut
but there are microbes present on every
surface internal and external and now
even implicated directly and indirectly
with the majority of organ systems in
the human body so it's kind of the dark
Internet of of biology the dark web dark
body yes I like that well we're you know
as the adage goes were more
microorganism than we are human
something like what is it like thirty
eight trillion microorganisms living
5050 5050 and half human but if you
don't count red blood cells which who
are we to eliminate from this equation
it's four to one Wow
yeah it's freaky when you start to think
that you're essentially a host working
symbiotically with all of these
life-forms to help us function and
thrive we we sometimes like T's we
almost say like you're an ecosystem so
the notion that
like you'd help someone there coral reef
or there a rainforest and it's a really
nice way of kind of giving a visual that
you are this kind of like teaming
ecosystem of these various species and
so it actually almost takes this notion
of a host yes in terms of the choices
you make and of course you have a lot of
agency over this ecosystem but this idea
that you know just like the natural
world like our bodies are no different
mm-hmm and this this gut flora and these
organisms that live all over our bodies
are incredibly diverse right we're
talking about bacteria viruses fungi
what is the breakdown protozoans
protozoa that's right
they live in their lashes and stuff well
they live in the gut I learned very
recently that they're the Predators of
that ecosystem so they go around
feasting on bacteria there's a whole
like the lion universe happening that
we're consciously unaware of right and
and so let's define our next term which
is gut health what does that mean I I
think the best place to start within
where the gut health is microbial might
your microbiome so modulating the
microbiome to have functional effects
that improve your status of health and
the second is that before you even get
to the microbes is a long winding
complex tissue system that both needs to
ward off pathogens but also selectively
absorb nutrients and so in terms of
reconciling those two somewhat at odds
skillsets requires a very specialized
set of skills and there's a number of
ways where the integrity of those
barriers the inflammatory responses the
metabolites that are produced the
signaling nerve signaling I would put
under the category of gut health as well
mmm-hmm and I think another I think it's
important your to your point about like
defining terms so what people refer to
so there's like what the public and like
you know kind of consumers believe about
gut health which is often gets conflated
with the microbiome so there's this idea
that you know you're
got is your microbiome and and that is
where the majority of these microbes
reside but what has happened I think a
lot in like the public perception is
that there's this notion that you know
your gut is your microbiome and
therefore what have what a lot of
products have tried to do and what a
particularly a lot of like dietary
recommendations have been like this
notion that you know once you kind of
understand that leader you're missing
some bacteria from this from this
ecosystem or you could kind of like
balance or restore it and you know
eating specific foods eating and so
there's been like kind of a lot of
conflation between this idea of gut
health and the microbiome whereas but
versus what Roger said which is if the
microbiome is all the microbes that
consist of you know of the different
ecosystems your body which includes your
skin and all these other external
surfaces right yeah the gut biome in the
Venn diagram the gut health is a subset
of the microbiome which is the macro
ecosystem of our bodies and when you
start to think of it in those terms the
permeation between human being and you
know the environments that we navigate
starts to kind of distal ate a little
bit right like we are our environment
and there is no like hard line that
distinguishes us from these organisms
that you know we host and the the
environments that we kind of navigate
and inhabit I'll give you another really
other another way to say that if you
think about it it's of course so obvious
to everyone that your skin is an
external surface but I think if you
think about the fact that we are to hold
organisms which means that the whole
from our mouth to our anus is actually
an external surface its outward facing
yes it's actually outward facing so if
you think about the notion that like
food or anything that you're putting
into one hole is like the same way that
you think about putting on skincare
right or putting on like moisturizer or
sunscreen so there's this notion that it
you know food is kind of information
it's an external factor the same way
like any environmental factor is it's
it's a form of information and so it's
an interesting way to kind of think
about this internal system which is only
separated to Rogers point from the
rest of your body by a very thin wall
which is why the integrity of that is so
important and I feel like we're as a
culture becoming more attuned and
conscious of the foods that we're eating
you know the idea that whatever we put
in our body becomes us and we're more
mindful of that connection but I feel
like we're only just starting to
recognize that same paradigm with
respect to what goes on our skin I mean
the world is rife with you know Beauty
products and all kinds of things that we
lather our bodies with that we don't
think twice about what's in them and
what's happening to us biologically by
you know they're consistent use yeah I
would actually go a step further and say
and you know one of the things that has
happened is that the evangelism has way
way outweigh the evidence so the word
microbiome the word probiotic gets used
so much more often than there is
evidence for and so skin is a great
example because it is the next kind of
skin and kind of oral health will
probably be these next categories where
every aisle you walk down every page of
Amazon you're gonna start to see the
word microbiome and/or probiotics either
the idea that there's probiotics or
prebiotics in the product or that the
product has been tested for your
microbiome and to be good for and or
what Duff calls
microbiome gentle even though there's
really no science for many of those
claims and so it we're still gonna be in
an era where the marketing is gonna be
way ahead of the science in most of
these categories well the FDA doesn't
regulate it at all right so this is just
another example of you know capitalist
interest co-opting what happens to be
popular in the Wellness vernacular at
the moment for the sake of you know
consumer interest right like you could
slap that label on it just like you can
slap on all natural or anything else and
it's essentially meaningless it has
become less meaningful but we obviously
think that there's a huge opportunity in
creating a standard for what does
constitute a probiotic and actually kind
of stewarding you know the through your
point about deaf
missions what actually is the scientific
definition of a probiotic Roger just
wrote a paper on yeah well let's talk
about that we're defining our terms here
so let's define the term probiotic so
probiotics are live microorganisms which
confer a health benefit on the host
there's a couple of key definitions that
that are sub definitions within that the
first is if it has not been tested in a
human population for the claim that's
being made then it is not a probiotic
so that means double-blind randomized
placebo-controlled studies
scientifically looking to show that that
organism has a probiotic effect one
popular trick that we see a lot of
commercial interests and corporations
use is they'll test a probiotic strain
for one very specific or small or niche
outcome like let's say I don't know
antibiotic associated diarrhea for
example but then they'll position the
product as if it has utility for a wide
audience preventively or proactively and
there's just no information to suggest
that so I think that we really want to
see companies and satin researchers this
isn't even just a company's thing this
is the term and in the lexicon is used
and thrown around to basically capture
any organism which could have a benefit
or that's theoretically could have a
benefit or even just anything that's
been fermented that's how broad this
category is gone we're all fermented
foods are not being positioned as
probiotic to butt or lice it's right
like it like in in skincare yeah so lie
sites are organisms that are heat killed
and then ripped open and just the cell
wall is being used and applied and those
are called probiotic all the time so
it's it's very very important that the
definition included the organisms being
live being delivered in the appropriate
dosages and having testing done on the
indication in the population that it's
being marketed to huh well you're like I
don't know what its title is chief
science officer did this guy dr. Gregor
Reed he was one of the guys who who
basically co-founded how we define these
terms right bye wait for the for
world health organization in the UN yeah
he chaired the the panel that actually
authored the scientific definition in
2001 for the UN and w-h-o doctor reads
published more papers on probiotics than
any other scientists in the world he's
at which he reminded me when we were
co-authoring this paper together that
he's authored 527 more papers than me at
one argument we had well like what do
you how old are you you're super young
he's two or very precocious early
thirties and a very accomplished early I
did not take any offense to it I thought
it was I thought it was a very comical
statement doesn't almost anything to me
but I just thought it was but but he
does scientific establishment and people
that are very prolific you know sciences
uh is a field that is based off of your
past work and so it's not a moot point
that somebody is a significant author
and thought leader in the field I mean
he did chair the panel that author of
the definition so I left that one slide
so he's written five hundred some-odd
twenty twenty-nine papers twenty-nine
papers okay counting and but there's
there's thousands of studies out there
right now on got health microbiome
probiotics prebiotics all of that and
yet there's a huge you know problem or
gap between fact and fiction and hype
and reality so can we kind of dive into
that and hopefully bridge that a little
bit yeah I mean it it goes back again a
little bit to the fact that the the term
itself is used so loosely not just on
products but also from a dietary
perspective like Roger mentioned like
fermented foods and beverages are kind
of you know a lot of people just say
I'll drink a kombucha and I don't need
to take a probiotic and I think that's
partially just because the term itself
has become so so diluted meanwhile it's
the entire area of inquiry like it on
you know and within microbiome science
and I think it's a it's especially
important to because in the in the
future particularly as we look at areas
like you know fertility the treatment of
pathology and disease the way we're
going to
metabolize chemotherapy the way we're
going to think about vaginal health and
and preterm births in the developing
world
I mean probiotics have such potential to
make a huge huge impact and not just
because of their health impact but also
from the affordability compared to other
medications the lack of side effects
compared to other their medications or
other complications and I think we we
really feel that there's such an
important part of our coz not just the
science and to create what we believe
are some of the most sophisticated and
effective products but to really steward
the translation of it and to really be
able to call out you know evangelism
over evidence and to really start to
make that distinction so that as they
start to play an increasingly important
role in our lives and in our health by
the way not just and we can get into
this not just for humans but for the
environment whether it's soil or or
water in our case probiotic for
honeybees that we've that we've been
working on you know if if everyone
thinks that every tortilla chip you can
just throw probiotics on or your shampoo
is just ever you know just throw some
microbes in its probiotic obviously
those things are not going to get taken
as seriously and actually as a result
you know when we've seen areas of
science where public perception shapes
and and hinders funding and the ability
to move some of these areas forward and
so I think that's for us like part of
really big important part of mission
right and really a big call for
something very simple specificity so
what a particular trick that bothers me
a lot is when companies reference
abstractly the importance of the
microbiome say it's been implicated with
everything from autism to
neurodegenerative disease to Alzheimer's
and your immune system and they
reference all these appropriate
scientific studies that show
associations between the microbiome and
those disease states but then in the
next tab it tells you a product that's
never been tested in any of those
populations and so I think that if
companies and researchers are more
specific and if we can educate consumers
to follow the trail trade ask for the
studies ask for the
search what's been done I mean / -
specifically like it's not it's not it's
hard to make those types of claims for
specificity while damp and dampen the
enthusiasm at the same time because it
is very true I mean there will be
microbial interventions for everything
from as our I mentioned cancer therapy
to the prevention and treatment of food
allergies to neurodegenerative disease
and we see our tracking and our research
divisions and our company on all three
of those areas so we know the research
and we know the researchers doing the
best work in those areas none of the
products that have ever made it to
market or will in the next year or two
have evidence for those indications so I
think that's really important to note
yeah my sense is that this is just an
unbelievably complicated science that
we're only beginning to you know
understand at a very base level but on a
consumer level we want to just think
like hey you know I I drink my kombucha
and I have my Greek yogurt and I
occasionally put kimchi on my food and
like I'm dealing with my probiotics and
I'm like all good so you know let's
dispel you know misconceptions around
kind of what the typical you know sort
of thought pattern is or behaviors are
around like the products that are
carnelian so fermented foods
definitionally are very different
category than a probiotic it's a pre it
would be a pre but considered a
prebiotic unless it's been shown to
modulate the microbiome it's not even a
pre body it is just a fermented food
that is the category and I'll give you
an example so a study was done that did
a deep metagenomic sequencing and kimchi
on a kimchi product and of the 900 or so
different strains that were found from
the lots that were tested only four are
believed to have probiotic potential or
were advanced into just showing that it
as a probiotic potential I think that a
lot of the benefits and fermented foods
come because the bacteria actually pre
digests a lot of the components and
roughage that for some people are very
difficult to handle so they're fibrous
and they're delicious so this is not a
PSA against fermented foods we think
they're great and certainly been used in
ancestral populations for the purposes
of food
servation for a very very long time if I
didn't have a refrigerator my diet would
be 70% fermented foods but the
fermentation process itself is bacterial
growth right are these not like sort of
you know positive organisms that we want
to introduce into our biome they don't
stay there very long
they don't colonize and so in fact I
would say more than more important than
the organisms that are used for
fermentation are the organic acids and
fermentation byproducts and some of
those metabolites that we believe could
be used by the human body to have a
health benefit but these studies are few
and far between and so the research is
really really lacking and what about
kombucha so kombucha is a complex
community that's part fungi part
bacteria interestingly enough some
studies show that non commercial
kombucha can have a pretty interesting
effect in the regulation of the
inflammatory cytokine release profile
that's that's resulted in the body and
so I think that but again these non
commercially available non-treated non
pre pasteurized are very much more
complex communities and so I even heard
one study where Akram and SIA was found
in an ancestral or indigenous kombucha
culture from the far north of Canada so
Ackerman's didn't you read the articles
Ackerman's is a very very interesting
bacteria which is lives and it sounds
like it's from like an avatar yeah it's
it's one of my favorite names there's a
there's another bacteria which is a
really cool name so the - and the the
most recent gut brain access paper that
were deficient in a thousand person
trial and in people with depression were
copper caucus and died Alistair I think
balusters sounds pretty nefarious - very
Game of Thrones
yeah but Aquaman says really interesting
it's a a strict anaerobe that means it
hates oxygen and it lives exclusively
along what's called the mucosa so that's
the lining of the gut where the mucous
layer is and these or
are what's called butyrate producers so
they produce this short chain fatty acid
directly which has two benefits the
first is that it's a factual fuel source
for your human epithelial colon cells so
that was a really breakthrough finding
when you see that actually human cells
have evolved to use bacterial products
as a primary fuel source for
proliferation for metabolic activity so
that just goes to show you how intimate
the relationship between humans and
bacteria and some ecosystems or body
sites really are
and the second is butyrate we believe
signals systemic processes in the body
so one of our research tracks is also
looking at the role that butyrate has on
regulating type 2 diabetes and actually
making the body more effective at
clearing glucose from the bloodstream
with the same amount of insulin mm-hmm
so that's why these are some really cool
bugs right and actually the way Roger is
describing it is like a really important
distinction to school you were talking
about how to like break this down for
like the general consumer looking at
probiotics so this it's really important
to think about that a microbe could be
taken so you could actually consume
bacteria to have a specific effect that
it has been studied for which is very
different than the way my probiotics are
currently marketed which is this idea
that it's good bacteria that you have
some good bacteria but that you're
missing some in your gut and then you
take a probiotic and it puts it back
which is two very different ways of
thinking about them but the scientific
definition is the former which is that
you consume bacteria and that has been
demonstrated to have an effect on the
human body and so and that's the
difference which is in the where the
marketing is right now is this notion
that you kind of like restore or put the
good stuff back versus that it has an
effect in the body and that by taking it
continuously because probiotics are in
Roger was talking about colonization
which is another good myth to bust and
that there's a lot of people who think
that a probiotic must colonize in order
to quote-unquote work but in fact
probiotics are transient which means
that they do their work kind of on the
road on their way through your body and
so that's an important distinction that
I think a lot of people kind of don't
understand
yeah that's new to me like I thought
okay
take this you you sort of seed it to use
your phraseology and then you colonize
it and you populate it and you feed it
and you you're like a farmer to your own
gut right but now you're saying well
there's a different term that's called a
fecal transplant I envision a future in
which there are high-end tawny salons
where you go in and get your you know
your your artisanal fecal transplants to
meet your every need
biodynamic poop in a pill yeah
alright so kombucha no bueno well maybe
if you make it yourself if it is a low
sugar or no sugar fermented beverage
that has high polyphenolic content from
teas it could be a health promoting
beverage we just urge caution around
using that calling it a probiotic just
because it has bacteria well there's
this sort of sense that we can
universally you know claim certain
probiotics to just be panaceas like I
just take this pill whether it's VSL 3
or whatever it is and I'm dealing with
it but you know to take it back to what
we're talking about a moment ago it's
it's like it's just way more complicated
than that right and and also like you
know another another like important
distinction and it's interesting it's
very few there aren't a lot of
categories that gets spoken about by
they're like generic name so we always
say like saying I take probiotics is
like saying I like books or like I eat
food and then someone asks you what food
you eat you're like no no I eat food and
there's thousands of strains of bacteria
and so there's a there's also a lack of
specificity in the strain a lot of
people who take for example if you say I
take supplements most people aren't like
well which which ones you're like no I
just take supplements there's obviously
quite different big difference between
taking d3 and omega-3s so um there's no
like currently we're at the place where
what the marketing has done is instead
of creating specificity around the
strains which is actually understandable
because they're so hard to say is that
they've been gone to indication
so you can walk into a grocery store
pharmacy today and see like one for mood
one for digestion one because there's
there really is no the consumer doesn't
know the difference between all these
strains and they think the category is
just generally like oh it's the same
reason that you could just drink a
kombucha and think you're taking
quote-unquote probiotics but actually I
mean there's thousands of strains of
bacteria and obviously it's very
different to eat a french fry than an
avocado and it's kind of this you know
the same there's just no specificity to
roger's kind of earlier point what is
the difference between strain and
species species are like dogs strains
are like all the different breeds mm-hmm
and it's important for bacteria because
some strains within the same so a
species is like lactobacillus rhamnosus
or lactobacillus acidophilus acidophilus
is the species lactobacillus of the
genus strain is what comes next and
that's within the rim lactobacillus
rhamnosus or within the lactobacillus
acidophilus those are strains within the
acidophilus species and for for one
particular species like lactobacillus
ruyter i which a lot of people have
really latched onto because MIT
basically gave it to mice and their fur
became very lustrous and they started to
exhibit signs of youth and vitality and
reproductive behaviors of younger mice
and so everyone got really excited
thinking that you know yogurt makes you
young again but there's some strains of
Reuter eye that are 70% genetically
different from other strains of the same
species there's no other taxonomic
species there's there's no other
category of the Tree of Life where you
find such difference within at the
species level it's insane so specificity
again at the strain level some strains
some strains of the same species are
shown to help IBS other strains the same
species make it worse so it's right so
when you when you buy a probiotic
product and it says I forget the acronym
they use but like you know 800 billions
you know strains of this that and the
other like how do we how do we as
consumers try to understand there's two
main tricks that are used
the first is that they'll call out the
speed if you look at the back they'll
have two Latin words and not a strain
designation so they'll just take these
generic species that have the highest
yield because they're cheaper to
manufacture rather than the ones which
are about rather than discovering and
doing clinical work I mean it's it's a
bit insulting to us because we're a
pretty deep life sciences company that
has multiple ongoing trials and human
clinical support for all of our strains
and you know it's that's that's the
first big trick and the second is a
large number on the front which actually
doesn't mean anything that's just a
number of colonies that those organisms
find so if a strain is very impotant
then sometimes brute force can be
effective like the VSL 3 operates on on
the brute force approach but there have
been some probiotic studies that show
efficacy with as little as 2 billion and
there's even some studies that show that
there's efficacy when the organisms are
heat killed or they're dead so there's
no direct relationship between the
number of organisms or the size of the
car and the intelligence of the driver
so it's yeah it sounds impressive though
yeah I mean and I think what what I
think what has happened is that
marketers realize that you could
merchandize you could have it's kind of
like many other categories where you
have like maximum strength and regular
and they realize that the higher the CFU
number the the consumer would believe
the stronger the product and therefore
they the therefore more expensive and
one of the other loopholes that happens
too is that they will reference some
clinical studies or research but if you
go back to the research the dosage that
was used in the clinical study is not
the dosage that's in the product it
wasn't their strength or it wasn't their
strain they'll be they'll be referencing
research at this at the UM at the
species level not at the strain level
and so there's a lot of tricks to to the
labels that you know we get asked all
the time well then how the hell do you
know what to buy and if people are not
gonna go depends why we started this
company so you know it's it's a hard you
know Roger always says well you got to
ask the company what are your studies
what are your and you know and he is you
are right but but the burden we part of
the reason that we founded seed and
in all the ways that we and what we've
talked about in terms of where we see
the future of you know microbiome
science going as it can impact consumer
health is important but a lot of why we
started it was that there was no
specificity and precision and really no
no no one to trust because we don't
think the burden should be on the
consumer it can't be it can and it can't
be because even if they got this study
they wouldn't know what to do with it
and I think we felt that there was a
huge opportunity and and you know
scientists as well and one of the things
and one of the reasons that many
scientists don't put their name on
consumer health companies is because
they don't operate with the kind of you
know that it's it's too easy to do those
loopholes and to to take those shortcuts
but when you have scientists that have
tenure or academic standing or funded by
you know government grants you know they
can't take those risks and so one of the
reasons that they you end up more
involved in kind of drug trials or drug
companies or biotech companies is
because they are going through FDA phase
trials which do have regulatory around
them and so what we really wanted to do
is say well what could we how could we
create that regular self-regulation and
what would that mean as we start to
think about creating that new standard
of bacteria right so explain how it is
that you know what what it is that
you're doing that's different
so across our division as a company we
have everything from consumer health
products to areas where we're engaging
with the FDA to make prevention and
treatment claims for disease so we
aren't we put the product or the
category in the box that is best suited
for for that area our first launch was
to actually to our s point make a lot of
bring clarity to this consumer health
world of bacteria that could be
beneficial not just in a way that's
Integris to the science but in ways that
could benefit otherwise healthy
individuals and so we don't think that
probiotics should or the ingestion of
live bacteria you know one of the things
that has resonated really well is that
you know for the majority all of human
existence the only levers that we've had
to impact health our diet lifestyle
factors like exercise cessation of
negative behaviors like smoking or being
set
sedentary or drugs and now we're finally
at a stage where we can harness the
power of microbes or bacteria to improve
or to push that vector proactively in in
in many different ways and we design
studies and tests that actually
corroborates this for health individuals
so I'll give you an example we actually
designed a test for our product where we
take intestinal epithelial cells which
are the linings of the gut and we apply
an agressor so an agressor in this case
is lipopolysaccharide which are
endotoxins from negative bacteria that
are in your gut they're actually the
most potent inducer of an inflammatory
response that so in the clinic they're
used as to replicate powerful or induce
a powerful inflammatory cascade and a
number of other different areas and we
tried coating them with our strains
before and then inducing the
inflammatory response and then applying
it afterwards and in both cases we found
not only for does this quickly down
regulate or dampen the inflammatory
response in your gut that results in
barrier breakdown or barrier dis
integrity but it also protects that
initially the severity of that response
to begin with so that's a really
interesting way that people have never I
mean any there's a number of things that
on a day to day basis can cause a
breakdown of barrier function a high
intensity interval exercise training is
one of them and normally people
associate that with being good for
health alcohol NSAIDs antibiotic use
high fat high fat diets
stress low sleep there's a number of
conditions that are associated but then
of course crowding stress anxiety
there's a number of and and so someone
once asked me well can you hypothesize
why something like high interval
training would cause an auto temporary
opening of loosening of the gut barrier
and I said well there's no way to to
possibly design a test for this but
think about you know kind of in a
primitive time if you were in had severe
exercise or in pursuit of something
wouldn't your it be a way for your body
to get cues as to what you're ingesting
or what you're pursuing or if you're
there's some sort of exposure
environment
exposure that you'd want your immune
system to come into very close contact
with what's passing through that
external surface and so of course
there's no way to know it but
intuitively it makes a lot of sense but
that's something that a otherwise
healthy individual could benefit from on
a day-to-day basis is maintaining
barrier integrity for the entire length
or duration of that of that organ system
and so that's one area but back to your
question about what how and what we
approach and what makes I think our
research track different tracks
different so we assembled a collection
of strains from our top academic labs
from academic collaborations and
commercial partners from all across the
world our fermentation and our academic
partners are in Scandinavia they're in
northern Italy they're in southern
France they're in Japan they're in
Cambridge Massachusetts and our core
thesis is that we have mechanistic and
human research for all of these strains
and so the store the study that I like
the best
was published in 2010 in the Journal of
Clinical gastroenterology and that shows
that the and a 300 person trial that
daily use of our strains results in
improvements across five key areas of
digestive health namely intestinal
transit time stool consistency stool
hydration ease of expulsion and bloating
bloating / flatulence right and why are
those factors important well those are
those are the course those are the core
factors that you use to score and assess
your digestive health so if you're
having appropriate muscle contraction so
foods moving through at an adequate rate
if your stools of the appropriate
consistency which means that my
microbial activity is sufficient to
metabolize your food into appropriate
stool if you're not straining which
means that you don't have constipation
or constipation associated effects you
don't increase your risk factors for
hemorrhoids there's kind of a
constellation of effects that are
downstream of poor digestive function
with these being the physical parameters
that you can use to assess the score of
your digestion and so if you ask people
you know and those are just the
biophysical ones if you look in terms of
quality of life
and you ask people what are the things
that change their quality of life almost
instantly it's it's affecting digestion
or the way in which people process food
or digest their food and so we were
pretty blown away when we found out that
six to eight million Americans have
chronic constipation like this isn't
just something that's on the coasts
right this is yeah I wasn't they would
you know of course is related to of
course I wonder how many of those people
are taking some form of opiate
absolutely any things I mean I what one
thing that is striking and and kind of
amazing is the the extraordinary rise in
got disorders and gut permeability
issues everything from IBS to Crohn's
ulcerative colitis like what I was
younger I didn't know anybody that
suffered from these problems and now
like it's you know you just hear it
every single day people are really
having problems with this so going back
to this idea of us being you know a
micro or us as humans being a micro
organism and the macro organism you know
this my sense is that these problems are
much larger than hey you should change
your diet like it goes to you know
deficiencies in our soil and the toxins
that we breathe and what we're putting
on our skin and the you know the
processes that go into these foods that
were like all of these factors you know
anxiety and stress and all of this are
creating a level of chronic oxidative
stress and a cascade you know a domino
effect of all other you know any number
of biological factors that are
contributing to these chronic ailments
that just weren't part and parcel of
life in 1975 that's that emanates from
directly from the hygiene hypothesis
which is as we've become cleaner and as
we've become quicker and to treat and we
do so more frequently in some instances
where there's nothing to treat at all
that we remove these mic reverse' T of
microbes that were exposed to
particularly in these windows of the
so there's a couple key windows the
first is the moment a moment in first
days of birth the second is the duration
up until you get to a steady-state
microbiome when you're an infant so the
first six months a two to three years is
when it reaches steady state but that
period of time between when you move
from breast milk to solid food that
weaning process and then of course
that's the microbiome that you have in
its steady state for the majority of
your life so barring factors and how
many people you know these today that
don't take have never taken antibiotics
I mean it's it's few and far between so
like this the the decrease in you know
of course the the overuse of antibiotics
but also the decrease in breastfeeding
right I mean that's what brought you
into this from the beginning right can
you share that story absolutely I am
I met Roger actually when I was pregnant
when we started kind of thinking about
what we were gonna build and I think
that you know I I've always been
somebody who's been really curious about
how particularly with the rise of
wellness you know it seems like we've
moved far further from science in some
ways and partially due to how powerful
some of these marketing ideas are and I
think how much agency they think they
they the illusion of agency over our
health and some in some cases with some
products animal a'f I'd buy you know a
general distrust of you know that's out
there based upon past experiences of
people of have and and I think you know
one of the things about science too is
that it does get fairly conflated with
like Western medicine and big pharma but
there is this methodology of of science
that I've always found like really just
intriguing and actually quite spiritual
and which we can go into you go yeah
spiritual yeah yeah I mean well it's a
methodology of asking a question and
having an experiment with no attachment
to the outcome so it it's for the way
that Roger and I kind of got to know
each other was very much through and
particularly when you're pregnant you're
bombarded with you know the internet
knows you're pregnant so every algorithm
every ad every
I mean it retargeting I mean it's
incredible you know just kind of the
messages and not to mention that many
people's unsolicited opinions of what
you should not be doing and eating and
taking and so I think it was really
through our getting to know each other
and and of course as you've heard today
just I think Raja has such a unique
ability to kind of synthesize and be
able to communicate and kind of really
think about these ideas from a place
that is actually not grounded in like
well how do you make a lot of money from
this but actually kind of like what what
really best serves the human and
development and he and he when we met
already was starting to think about this
kind of critical window of development
particular round the microbiome and I
had actually just come out of actually
just before I got pregnant a miscarriage
and I had resigned from my previous
company and I was really just thinking
about what I wanted to create and use
use these my skills for and what I
wanted to put out in the world and a lot
of what we started talking about and how
we really bonded was around kind of all
this translation this translational
peaceful what was going to build this
bridge between science and in our case
the microbiome and the science that was
coming out of that and getting it to
humans consumer health and so we were
really building but it but it wasn't
really until after I had my child that I
could only supply about a third of his
breast milk after about four months and
after you spend a year focused in the
space and certain and really
understanding kind of this critical
window that Rasha just spoke about it is
quite actually heartbreaking when you
know what you should be doing and what
you would like to be doing and that the
only answer is that someone just says
get the expensive stuff from Europe
which is just not to an entrepreneur is
like the last accessible answer and to a
mom is like unacceptable and I think
that was really like my inception point
is from like and I mean obviously as
many women know her probably listening
right now right when you have a child is
not the first moment where you're like
I'm gonna start a new company but it
really was for me like an aha moment
around well really who is creating this
bridge because if that's the best answer
and I had access to great doctors to two
people who were supposedly quote-unquote
experts it's it
just wasn't there was no acceptable
solution I think particularly when you
look at how fast understanding that
infants developing microbiome is
progressing in the scientific space in
an academia especially we really felt
that we could at least start the company
from this notion of what would it mean
to create the evolution of formula and
supplementation options for women I
couldn't breastfeed or who chose who
made a choice to stop breastfeeding and
so that was really where seed started on
seed seeding being them you know
biological term for an infant's first
exposure to microbes kind of the seeds
of their microbiome that was really
where we began and when we started
building and we realized we were
building this extraordinary bridge
between a cadet the academic science and
some of the most cutting-edge and
leading researchers in the world in the
space and the ability to and especially
through Rajas expertise in the
translation and how that would make its
way to a product we realized that there
was this huge opportunity to really take
that platform and then start applying it
to other areas where we felt their
research where where where a product
would not reflect evangelism over
evidence and where we felt that actually
there was sufficient evidence to
substantiate creating something that we
thought could be really impactful in
someone's life yeah I want to get into
those downstream products that you're
that you're developing right now it's
super interesting but while we're kind
of here on childbirth child-rearing you
mentioned Raja a moment ago that that an
infant's microbiome is essentially
locked in at birth is that no so there's
so in fact it's totally a blank slate at
birth of going up to birth okay so if
you wanna hear a little bit of science
of drama so there's love science for all
that there's two opposing fields and
both are led by incredible female
scientists that are very strong and
opinionated and at conferences as
everyone knows it's uncomfortable when
they give talks right after each other
they fight on Twitter they some version
of that usually and in the it's in the
peer review in the peer review sections
of journals and is where they
they go out at each other but one
believes that the infant is not born
sterile we're sorry in other words that
in the mother's bacteria from her mouth
migrates through the body into the
developing infant prior to the moment of
birth through the canal no no it
migrates through the body like it the
ingestion of oral microbes migrates into
the baby across the placenta uh-huh
while the baby is still what is in utero
is that the term and and then ever the
other set camp says absolutely not
bacteria evolved too quickly if one
bacteria was able to do that in other
would quickly learn that skill set and
go in high jacket and we our infant
mortality rate would be much higher and
then the other camp says well look at
this 360 or so person data set that we
found showing that that is the case and
the other group says no that's
contamination and so it goes back and
forth a little bit in that way but then
the other main school of thought says
the infant doesn't have any organisms
until the moment where it passes through
the birth canal right and then that's
where it picks up the mother's
lactobacilli and if you think about it
humans are the only mammals or certainly
the only Apes that give birth in a
hospital on their back on a table I mean
normally the way that the human posture
would be designed to be something of a
hunching or leaning over process and you
could imagine that alongside microbial
exchange there'd be other bodily
substances and fluids that would be
exposed set this up the word sure is
right now yeah at that period I think a
lot of women argue that there are many
other bodily fluids yeah but to get to
the the point of it like those fluids
during a vaginal birth are absolutely
critical in forming the microbe
there's a trifecta of out of way there's
three core ways that you could impact
the microbiome from infant that we
believe that an infant should be exposed
to vaginal birth and access to bodily
fluids
breastfeeding and not consuming
antibiotics or cessation of antibiotic
use within that first six six month
window of time and also there's
microbial transyl from the from the
mother's nipple areola that is it's
where most of the Bifidobacterium reside
and even again there's strong evidence
now to suggest that breast milk isn't
sterile and that there's a microt that
you get beneficial organisms in breast
milk itself so why breastfeeding is so
important of the three the most
important is breastfeeding if you
breastfeed consistently and are able to
it generally would over at least in
terms of epidemiological studies would
overpower the risk factors of of
c-section or of early stage and
technologies so have there been
long-term studies performed on children
that were born through cesarean
c-sections or children that were raised
without breast milk yeah and and the
incidence of you know I don't know
whether it's got got disorders or other
kinds of I don't mean yeah that relate
to microbiome health not in a way where
they're controlled so not an
interventional study but observational
studies have shown a higher prevalence
of allergic sensitization and atopic
disease and immune disorders in infants
that were not breastfed or again it's
confusing because you usually anti
cesarean or antibiotic use or not
breastfeeding
it doesn't cluster neatly into private
categories because usually some ones
that somebody just one miss - exactly
fine but but your sense is that if if a
child is born via c-section that
whatever deficiency you know it might
have coming out of the gay can be
overcome through breastfeeding
breastfeeding antibiotics right
skin-to-skin contact contact with the
mother's nipple diverse exposure to
micro organisms animals animals and
house and dietary products that that
have antibiotics right of course and
pesticides and the like I would imagine
you know we live in this Purell culture
I think we're getting we're getting hip
to you know the antibiotic thing in a
way that we haven't previously but you
know I know people very well that you
know have taken you know long term
courses of antibiotics over the years
and now have all kinds of issues that
they really mean that are just
debilitating for them and no matter what
health protocol they pursue they always
end up quite ill from time to time I
mean and I think we're just going to see
more and more of this so what are the
what are the larger kind of diseases
chronic ailments out there that you're
seeing that are in your minds like a
direct result of poor gut health well I
want to start by saying that there are
some antibiotics probably are
responsible for extending human life
more than any other intervention so I
just want to make very clear that if you
need an antibiotic if you have a
bacterial infection take it
some studies are now showing that the
majority or the bulk or at least 90% of
the microbiome recovers maybe not in its
full vigor as it was before but within a
six month period of time watchful
waiting it's called
is is still effective for it's not that
there's an irreversible decimation
that's gone forever and so there's a
it's very bad and there's but we don't
know what other downstream effect is my
point we don't know what those periods
of time do to cause risk factors for
other conditions that like the ones you
just thought like you just referenced
but in terms of a dis patek microbiome
and what that can cause I mean again you
have to take into account that the whole
field is just discovered for the most
part in 2006 and so long term illnesses
were remaining to see to be seen
mechanistically we've established that
there's a very interesting and clear
link between conditions as severe as
Parkinson's disease Alzheimer's disease
the whole window or cluster of
neurodegenerative diseases there's a
mediation of the gut liver access and
the gut skin access so atopic dermatitis
psoriasis eczema
we have interventional studies showing
that modulating or the administration of
bacteria can damp in a reverse atopic
skin conditions
via the gut liver access they can
attenuate cholesterol or lipid levels or
lipoprotein levels in in ways that are
we believe are better for health your
LDL cholesterol and your V LDL
cholesterol stay a little bit low the
particle number two not just the count
and the particle size what else
that's what about autism oh boy I mean
that's a really really loaded question I
can tell you that I know the perfect
bacteria to decrease the risk of autism
in mice mm-hmm - but I know two bacteria
that be very good at decreasing the risk
of autism or you can diagnose autism and
mice Oh mice that I bought - autism I
skip mice can be read for autism autism
spectrum disorder they they stick to
themselves they don't socialize well
they don't have engaged in community
dynamics there's there's a very very
good animal model in in mice for autism
and autism spectrum disorder look these
things are very multifactorial and I
will tell you that I've even seen I
don't think this data is published yet
but some data showing that probiotics
work and alleviating the symptoms of
autism disorder but again the question
is gut in the GI issues are one of the
most common comorbidities with autism so
the question is if you relieve the GI
distress does that then in turn end up
reversing some of the you know
behavioral behavioral expressions of
that disorder in the form of you know
violent or self violence or behavioral
extremes or or swings so it's it these
these things are very complex and
multifactorial I do think there's been
two very very good studies showing that
not only that when you knock out the
microbiome completely you increase the
risk of autism spectrum disorder so that
shows that bacteria are involved right
that much I can tell you is true
in terms of what bacteria please nobody
go and buy a probiotic that has the word
autism on their website because there's
no published studies that show that any
commercially available probiotics have
any
effect at all and in fact the organisms
that are most involved in those the
prevalence or the the presence of those
near active metabolites or GB the gut
brain access GBA are actually not
Bifidobacterium are not lactobacilli so
my point about the digestive relief more
science needed yeah basically what is
the impact in your mind of are basically
are just decreasing the decreasing
diversity of our biosphere in general
you know through our soil through the
you know our talk that are increasingly
toxic environment the way we you know
raise animals for food etc all of these
things playing into species extinction
you know all the way down to single-cell
organisms and smaller and the like how
does this play into gut health and how
we think about yeah I mean well Roger
can Roger it's kind of alluded to this
earlier wouldn't he spoke a little bit
about the hygiene hypothesis one of the
ways that like we try and kind of paint
this picture for for our community is
you know we talked a little bit about
this notion of like the climate change
of our insides right it's kind of like
you know you learned about like the the
lack of diversity or what's happening to
like our rainforest or you look at the
coral wave the way people like learn
about what's happening to a coral reef
in some ways so yes it's very much
exactly and so sometimes those are
really good kind of analogues for kind
of starting to understand like how
what's happening in the environment as
actually like analogous with what's
happening in our body and that's a
results obviously many of the things
that Roger just spoke about and so you
know one of the things that we are
looking at from a seed perspective and
we have a division of our of our company
called seed labs which is where we start
to look at the way in which microbes
could be a part of the solution so like
honey bees are like a really awesome
example yeah you guys are doing
something amazing and and actually about
to they'll be a there'll be a paper
published actually this summer about
some of the first first field trials for
honey bees but this looks specifically
at the impact
on the honeybee gut of neonicotinoid
pesticides and so you know what the ways
and and we have other projects that
looking to your point you brought up
soil and and and of course in our in our
world we're looking at you know other
ecosystems and also even how microbes
could play a role in the cleansing of of
water for example and even like the the
creation of said more sustainable
materials on like bio plastics but on
the honeybees all that Roger
I'll start by answering your question in
the two most dense microbial communities
on earth our soil and the human gut so
it goes to show you I mean just we're
depleting both both there's there's
that's to start with the definitions or
a truism about I think that that's a
really really interesting place to start
getting dirty is good the healthiest the
sexiest microbiome out is the Amish
microbiome I mean these guys don't get
sick they don't have allergy
sensitization they don't have chronic
degenerative diseases there's even been
studies that are published and
peer-reviewed in scientific journals
showing the inverse relationship of the
all modern diseases and Amish
populations and its relationship with
microbial communities that are found in
those areas so I never thought I'd say
those words but the Amish really are
leading the way the more I learn about
the Amish the more convinced I am that
they're they've really figured out there
was something in a way that we haven't
they keep coming up on the podcast was
it was it was it Cal Newport who was
talking about the Amish and there were
talking about their relationship with
technology and and and how they think
about innovation in terms of its
usefulness to the community they're not
totally Luddite they just do they run an
evaluation of purpose you know utility
versus distraction and they've been able
to maintain the integrity of community
and and I don't know man I think there's
a lot to be the community of the
microbiota repair
now we can we can just look at people's
microbiomes and so termination of a
scientific approach to that would be to
compare that to other agrarian societies
that have daily exposure with soil and
farm animals which are great exposures
of micro means to microbial diversity
and I bet that their microbiome is just
as healthy - so almost assured the most
interesting thing though about them is
that they exist so in such close
proximity with the built environment and
within and and so close to societies
that are organized so fundamentally
different which is that which is so so
interesting because they they truly are
this kind of counter culture and and I
mean if you look at areas of yeah it's
incredible it's the original more rock
than Punk maybe but they that I mean if
you took it look at like in Pennsylvania
like the proximity to New York City is I
mean it's extraordinary it what's ironic
is that you know you have all these
women you know the Amin there's a
there's like an underground like breast
milk ring that you live like breast milk
and you can buy all these like cultured
dairy products from like the Amish but
it's illegal in New York so it's like
buy them they have like red churches are
like trying some moms seriously it's
incredible
yeah because when I was looking for
supplementation options a lot of people
were telling me that you could buy we're
so dysfunctional but honeybees yeah go
is that is that where we are yes Amish
bees so we found an Amish bee yes the
most prized so the honeybee most people
here would know or have heard of the
this phenomenon called colony collapse
disorder which is for unexplained
reasons in the last 10 years or so mass
mass communities of honeybees are just
dying off indiscriminately we don't know
why the population is we really not know
why we are starting so that that's the
hook the answer is the lead to leading
causes or we the three leading causes
are habitat loss and have
doesn't just mean the wild as being less
wild it means monocot mana plant culture
of plants - so the streamline if ocation
streamlining the lack of diversity
that's the second is an emeritus a
pathogen called fallow brew disease it's
a nasty pathogen that kills honeybee
babies in the first three days of life
and the third Ernie Oh Nick it's annoyed
pesticides which the EU had banned last
year but the u.s. still allows and
they're called because they operate in
the Nikita noid and nicotinic receptor
sites in the brain which under
etymologically are related to what's
found in the tobacco plant so much so
that if you put a suspension of water
with glucose and water with nicotine Oh
nicotine no I'd passed asides honeybees
will pick the pesticide water over the
glue sugar water and that's that's a
completely crazy finding and so what it
does is it slowly disorients bees and
when it compounds and aggregates in
their bodies they forget they've just
get so disoriented that they just lose
their safer get where their hive is it's
it's kind of um it's really it's really
morbid interesting indication that cell
phone signals and Wi-Fi is contributing
to this or yeah whoo I haven't done it
is if it is contributing to it it is not
a I mean massive happiness we see this
happening in communities that have low
in in sites where there's low Wi-Fi and
low cell signal but there's high-class
aside you so it certainly would be less
it may it makes my radar go off but I'm
not sure I don't think that they access
these communities but but but the point
is that a new factor is we so this
thesis was when these environmental
changes happen the first thing that
changes is the microbiome and so there's
a lot of sequencing work that was done
or chief scientists in our first seed
fellow are the ones that are leading
these fed these these field trials and
we actually found that by reintroducing
three probiotic organisms back into the
bee gut you can a detoxifying
neonicotinoid pesticides before they're
absorbed into the body so it's it binds
and
leases these common pesticides and and
dampens or protects the immune response
as a result of it but perhaps more
impressively in early early bee
communities you know so so bees are
becoming something like Japan right now
or there's a lot of old bees but very
few young bees and they dramatically and
significantly protect these young bees
from crowding out this pathogen which is
so powerful that if it's found
beekeepers are supposed to go and burn
and score scorched earth the entire hive
to make sure it does within days of its
discovery because they can spread it can
spread very quickly even once more can
spread and result in an epidemic and a
different a neighboring hive so we we
published about this the first paper
came out in scientific reports in nature
using a Drosophila model that's a model
organism for honeybee populations field
trials just concluded last year we made
our announcement at the end of last year
and we Pat we patented this but then
opened up royalty-free the patent
honeybee farmers around the world and
then we hope at some point this real
year to roll out bio paddies and bio
sprays that are based off these species
after our UC Davis trial commences and
so this is a field a large-scale field
trial and almond farms which is kicking
off in a couple right so essentially
it's a probiotic right now it's a patty
it's like almost like it's like a
pancake okay so they eat in the hive and
that populates their gut flora was
something that helps them avoid the
negative impacts of these nicotinamide
of pesticides and of the foul brood
disease so two out of the three leading
causes of colony collapse disorder right
and just for people that don't know like
paint the picture of colony collapse
disorder you know at its you know at its
you know
ultimate yeah I these are the most
efficient pollinators that have or ever
will be discovered or invented if we
lose bee populations we lose nearly
every single
bloomin crop or fruiting crops that you
find maybe some in small quantities root
vegetables would persist but a lot of
the diversity that you see from
above-ground pollination is are
virtually gone I mean models that
predict it say that the supermarket the
the the fruits and vegetables aisles of
the supermarket be decreased by over 90%
if we lost so many bees yeah I mean the
easiest way to say it is whatever you
ate for breakfast this morning
probably won't be here and that's all
and there's also other implications like
cotton for example that have of course
other implications for other industries
and other uses right so it really
broadens the aperture on the work that
you're doing this is not just hey you
know like we want to create a probiotic
to make people healthy like it's really
an effort to address the declining
biodiversity of the planet at large and
the implications or the sort of
applications of this science that you're
developing are really limitless and and
I think also the applications of science
that's really often stay is kind of
guarded behind at you know in academic
institutions or for many reasons often
doesn't make its way to humans or for
other applications that can be
immediately kind of put to use and to
make an impact so that's part of kind of
the bridge we've built and very proud of
yeah one of the things that that really
blows my mind about the microbiome in
the human body is this developing
science and awareness around the
connection between the gut and the brain
and my first introduction to this was
through these studies that were done on
cravings and essentially in my most
laymen ability to describe this what I
took from that was that your microbiome
can literally essentially hijack your
nervous system and signal your brain to
crave certain foods that feed the you
know whatever it is that that floor
actually needs to feed on is that
accurate
can we like talk about like that because
that's crazy we think of ourselves as
sentient human beings we're making
decisions where we have self well and
you know all the sort of things we have
freewill and yet the idea that you know
these microorganisms that live within
our body are actually dictating yeah
what we crave and what we end up putting
in our mouth is kind of a mind-blower
well I guess am i exaggerating here no
so high fat consumption increases the
prevalence of organisms that are
lipophilic that just are fat loving and
it's unordinary most of the organisms
that are evolved for generations in
humans are carbohydrate loving or fiber
complex carbohydrate loving organisms
and so the community does change it's
unclear whether the microbes are driving
that or because your love of fat is
changing your might your microbes and so
it's hard to establish causation but
certainly we find that at least at a
macro nutrient level you see think these
things cluster really neatly based off
of what you can have an impact in the
organisms and then it creates a feedback
loop right so III think that there's
it's a digestion and cravings are
complex you're and sometimes the foods
that you had when you were there's a
developmental inputs there's
physiological inputs like some people
have certain tastebuds some people can't
eat brussel sprouts or cilantro or
stevia it just the the bitterness isn't
tolerated very well which strangely
enough is a defense mechanism from
potentially poisonous plants but there's
we do see very clearly that based off of
preference for for for food source and
diet and what constitutes a diet a very
clear clustering of organisms that are
that are in response to that so yeah I
think the the study if I'm recalling
correctly had to do with chocolate like
there was they they cultured the
microbiome of somebody who is like super
into chocolate and like addicted
chocoholic or whatever and then
implanted it in somebody else who was
neutral about chocolate and suddenly
they started craving chocolate so I
don't know if that's good science or not
but just anecdotally it's you know but
for somebody who is like could take our
leave chocolate to suddenly be like I
need chocolate now like maybe that
overbearing parents no no no but the
idea the person who was then implanted
with the chocoholics microbiome suddenly
having a what spontaneous what I will
tell you is that if that if those
results were in a large enough sample
size that that is the proper design for
to evaluate that that is elegant trial
design and I will look into the
chocolate story there was a fairly like
long press cycle after the appetite and
microbes press came out that was even
outside of the chocolate study there
there have been some others where they
do talk a lot about the the connection
and we get asked about it actually quite
a bit but a lot of it I have not heard
the chocolate one yet but we'll get back
to you on that well really the best
child is I'm gonna be if you knocked out
the microbiome of a new person and then
put the existing person for a micro
biome in there if they not gave them
chocolate because that could affect your
sensory but that could have a lot of
confounders but if you just gave
somebody antibiotics and an fmt of the
chocolate lovers uh-huh gut all right
right right cool let's talk about the
impact of the microbiome on some of the
you know chronic ailments that are you
know really our biggest epidemics you
know of our culture like heart disease
you know basically chronic ailments that
are a result of of chronic inflammation
yeah I know you guys have done some work
around cardiovascular disease and the
relationship between yeah
so the three big ones that I think are
worth starting with our
heart disease or atherosclerosis
metabolic syndrome particularly type 2
diabetes and obesity which one could
argue as part of metabolic syndrome but
will make it its own thing so heart
disease one of the leading most recent
triggers of heart disease so there's two
maguet into the nutrition warriors would
go back and forth and whether
cholesterol is good or bad and that's
neither here nor there for this debate
for this discussion but we believe or
manes
there's enough wealth of evidence to
show correlation between elevated
low-density lipoproteins or LDL and
atherosclerosis or risk factors for
heart disease and so most people don't
realize that actually that cholesterol
is produced by the liver it is very very
little if any in some people dietary
cholesterol actually enters into
systemic circulation so most of this is
he generated endogenously generated
cholesterol which then is recycled and
it can when when it's also released in
the form of digestion with bile salts or
bile acids it's there carriers of it so
then it's reabsorbed back up in your
colon and so this there's a strong
recycling process or shuttling and
recycling process for cholesterol uptake
and so bacteria actually many of them
can bind to cholesterol assimilate it in
their cell wall and prevent its reuptake
to maintain homeostatic cholesterol
conditions and so that's what we call
mediating the gut liver access but in a
way that could without any changes in
your diet or even if you have a genetic
risk factor maintain your cholesterol
levels and so we think we think that's
of course very interesting in other ones
a lot of people have hold of heard about
choline which is converted by gut
bacteria into a compound which is which
enters into circulation which is the
inflammable eve to be the inflammatory
trigger for an after-school erotic event
so you know the these are really two
interesting ways where module
of the either the microbiome or
modulation of the microbiome can
decrease your risk factor of heart
disease obesity was the first time that
people actually cared about the
microbiome because humans are pretty
vain and in 2006 they took the
microbiome of an obese Mouse and
transplanted it in a lean Mouse and vice
versa and their entire profile changed
and so that's when we learned that the
microbiome is involved in obesity there
give antibiotics are given
prophylactically to farm animals to get
them fatter for slaughter because it
regulates metabolic processes yeah what
is the mechanism because it you energy
utilization and so I sit extracts more
nutrients out of food mmm
whereas fibrous compounds bind to
bulking matter for elimination right so
yeah it's it's really it's really
interesting and so did again I don't
know which which is responsible for the
other but obese people can cluster with
a microbiome that's very different than
those that are lean and it's I'm very
conflicted about this because if I were
living in a pre-modern time I would want
the obese persons microbiome it's way
better at scavenging nutria extra energy
utilization from things that other
ordinarily people like you or I wouldn't
write anymore resourceful and and an
efficient yeah right using a sponge if
you in times of scarcity an obese
microbiome is a good microbiome the
problem is now we just live in a in a
time of abundance and so it's it's
complicated it's it's yeah that trait
could have been passed down as a
survival mechanism absolutely and so I
another example of that is away from
well you wouldn't get over this yeah but
oh yeah I mean you become very tasty so
is it possible that you can then develop
specific probiotic strains that are
meant to address specific conditions
absolutely and that's why our paper and
our comments earlier we're intended to
not cheapen the term probiotics because
this is what's happened the research
that's happening now we have these
several of these research tracts even
within our company and
certainly the scientific community is
looking at targeted probiotics for the
prevention and treatment of serious
conditions that are contributing to all
cause mortality but also affect a very
large number of human population a large
percentage of the human population is
there an application for your work that
can apply to soil diversity biodiversity
of soil yep so so soil diversity is one
of those things that as it progressively
becomes less diverse it's very hard to
add back in diversity that was lost and
so it's prevention is the best for
maintaining diversity but there's a
number of ways where bacteria and
microbes can dramatically increase our
the health of our soil and the health of
our crops so I'll give you two examples
so legumes are rely on a relationship
with nitrogen fixing bacteria otherwise
they wouldn't get or absorb nitrogen
whether it's artificial or used from a
synthetic source or whether it's
naturally occurring in the soil they
wouldn't be able to unlock and
metabolize it for growth of the plant
and so I think we don't know all the how
many plants have a microbial component
that are responsible for either nutrient
uptake or their nutritional density or
even it legumes are an extreme
circumstance because it's the ability
for those plants to exist in the first
place and so modulating or protecting or
augmenting those soil communities to
allow crops to flourish and the second
is a really interesting way where you
can look at a lot of different physical
parameters of a plant and what
determines its health and so we have an
area a track that we're researching on
three three key factors of Plant Health
so this is thicker stems earlier rooting
and more dense crop or fruit yield so
higher yield so all three of these
things can be altered based off of the
application of microbes or introduction
of specific microbes back into soil crop
communities and so there's a couple of
companies that are doing great work in
this there's a couple of companies now
that are really really trying to do to
think about this thing for mass market
mass crop farmer applications I'm
working with farmers to get this out
there
sometimes cheaper or at costs with the
pesticides and also really especially
important because one of the areas that
they're seeing that you can apply
microbes is to increase the drought
resistance to a lot of these plants
which of course is going to become
increasingly important right in specific
geographical areas which is different
from genetically modifying them oh
absolutely
alterations here you're restoring or alt
or fixing optimizing optimizing word
yeah the microbial community the
microbiome of the plant
other than the Amish what other what
where where are we seeing the healthiest
guts got guts in the world
yeah Denmark has a really healthy gut
yeah why I mean they're risk they're
diverse there's a lot of biotech life
science microbiome bioinformatics
research that's done in Copenhagen we
have a lot of research tracks and debt
based out of Denmark
I mean secret the diversity and its
relate inverse relationship with the
things like lifespan and degenerative
diseases are they're pretty high on life
span and and general happiness my thesis
is there's probably a very high
correlation between the no homework rule
and a good but actually you know one
thing that we didn't define at the very
beginning that just your question does
bring up which is what is the definition
of a healthy microbiome because I think
that there's a lot of misinformation
around like what this notion and what we
love to do particularly in the u.s. is
create a a goal will never reach so we
can just live in stress and scarcity
right we're really suffering we loves to
suffer so if we put healthy microbiome
out beyond the field at the end I will
just never reach it and I think I want
it so one of the things that happens it
when we talk about that is that there's
this notion that there's like kind of an
unhealthy and healthy as if there's kind
of one
one definition of that and one of the
interesting things and
any of our scientists were primary
investigators and the human microbiome
project that was you know a hundred plus
million dollar a research project that
it was initiated by the NIH under the
Obama administration and you know one
hundred plus million dollars and and the
answer was there is not one healthy
microbiome there are markers of a
healthy microbiome not surprisingly one
of them is diversity and and what they
call alpha alpha richness so but the
diversity is really one of the markers
but it's important because many and
going back to your very original
question about like what is how are
people hearing about you know microbiome
and probiotics this idea that you should
have a specific ratio of one strain to
another or it has to be these specific
types of strains is it's very hard for
us to grasp that like all three of us
sitting here could have quote-unquote
healthy micro biomes but actually have
quite different composition of them and
I think that's really AM it is really
important because there are a number of
companies and a number of kind of
content pieces that I've read online
books even us particularly about like
microbiome diets and kind of eating for
your micro personalization or take this
test and this is the right microbiome
see us tomorrow exactly as if there's
there's this kind of like one picture
when in reality what these companies are
doing is trying to gather as much data
as they can and hitting snooze on
actually answering the question of what
a healthy microbiome is so they're
trying to cluster people and say this is
an Alzheimer's microbiome this is this
and it's we think that it's very very
dangerous to start going down that that
road and I mean look we understand why
it's mean it's of course incredibly
compelling particularly and you and you
know this really well like I think we're
in this era where we we believe that
data is agency and so in the quants self
movement where you can measure
everything and then therefore know
everything and know what to do it it it
appeals to everybody's like I want to
know what's in there so then I can put
back what's missing or so that I know
what's like where I should like what I
should improve it just doesn't it
doesn't work that way yeah I want I
be able to take a sample and send it to
a lab and have an app on my phone that's
gonna break it down and tell me where
I'm deficient and what I need to do to
fix it so I can completely optimize it
wait but that's not the way it works not
yeah but the Amazonian Indians have
never heard of the term microbiome you
have to have a pretty damn good one
so there's contrary to everything that
we spent the last hour and half or so
talking about
there's also another recommendation
which is don't overcomplicate it
it's a lot simpler than we might think
it's have a diversity or an input of
more than 30 different fruits and
vegetables in any given week that's been
the highest correlator of a diverse
microbiome avoid excessive antibiotic
use avoid alcohol intake which rips up
your gut barrier don't be too clean like
sugar yeah yeah take showers huh do you
guys take showers oh I had I mean it's
been a long time but I had you know dr.
Robin shut can right okay I had her on
the show it was many years ago but yeah
her whole thing is like you know be
dirty and like you know we wash our hair
too like I basically stopped washing my
hair after I wash it like once a month
or something like that and like I don't
use soap like I used to and it really
changed how I think about you know
cleanliness and in the sense that you
know being dirty is the new clean and in
trying to cultivate you know a healthier
microflora that's all the problem isn't
with the showers or solder it's with
soaps yeah right right what are the
other things while we're kind of on this
subject people commonly do that they
shouldn't do or habits that they can
easily adopt that would be beneficial I
mean I would also say I mean Raja
alluded to it earlier you know that the
the N said so so the overuse you know we
antibiotics of course I think as you
said earlier kind of people are starting
to kind of be more wary and taking them
only when they need to but I think we're
very happy to pop Advil or motrin
ibuprofen like pretty pretty easily and
I think that's something that you know
it kind of is like that new lens right
where you know as all these things we've
always taken and just kind of
put in our bodies weren't tested for our
microbial selves and so things like
NSAIDs for example or a great a great
area to say kind of like antibiotics
like as needed a lot of I think people
take them much very promiscuously and
very prophylactically right so like oh
you're about to get your period you
guess you're like oh I don't get cramps
I'll take 800 milligrams of ibuprofen so
you know areas like that I think you can
make it really just like the simple
changes that you can kind of start to
like think about everything before you
take specific medicines having a dog or
a pet for example spending time in
nature I mean things that are probably
fairly intuitive but actually make an
impact
um good sleep crowding the microbiome
has its own circadian rhythm mm-hmm
which isn't true which is you yeah void
crowded spaces spend balance your time
in the built environment with the
unbuilt environment uh-huh it's funny
how nature seems to have rigged
everything to get us to live like the
Amish look the same thing that is
contributing to depression and anxiety
and stress and early mortality and like
you know the answers are always come
back to you know often come back to very
basic things that you know
intellectually we know and yet we have
such difficulty building back into our
daily experience I mean you know the
most interesting thing and as this
probably self-evident from this you know
this last hours so it's is you know I I
am an outsider in my in this world right
because I am NOT a scientist but what's
so fascinating is you know you you
really you you learn so quickly that you
can know lots of things whether no
matter what philosophy you know you
ascribe to you but science can know many
things but at the end of the day so much
of this is human decisions and human
behavior mm-hmm their decisions that get
made an industry there's like it's
decisions that get made around
conference room tables about marketing
and there's also decisions that get made
every day by humans in that moment where
you open a menu you stand in a grocery
store your
you you put something on your fork and
there is a there is a space probably
about 14 inches between what you're
deciding to do and what goes inside of
you and or other other decisions you
make us what time to to go to bed for
example whether or not to sit on your
phone for an hour and a half in bed
before you go to sleep I mean there are
things and and yet we know these things
and we and the it's the compliance of
them that is actually sometimes the most
challenging it's not that there aren't
any good products out there or that you
can't get a plant to eat in some kittens
of course in some places that are there
it is it is more difficult to get good
food but for the most part it comes down
very much to human human behavior mm-hmm
and the effects the effects go past your
own lifetime so this Sonnenberg lab at
stanford designed a really elegant trial
where they looked at three progressive
generations in an animal model and put
them on a low-fiber diet and found that
by the third generation even if you
switch them back to a high-fiber diet
the extinction has had happened and you
couldn't resurrect or bring back the
diversity from two three generations ago
so it's really interesting i mean these
are delicate ecosystems that co-evolved
with us for hundreds of thousands of
years they're also very versatile and
they're very responsive and they evolved
very quickly so what's inside of us also
wasn't inside a Paleolithic era which is
which is a really beautiful you know
beautiful idea one of the scientists
that we work with wrote a paper called
moving from ego system to eco system eg
o2e Theo and I think that you know when
you asked us we're talking about the
bees and you asked us kind of like what
seeds about you know there is the
stewardship there's this you know it is
not just about you when you're a mother
of course you understand this deeply and
in some ways but when you start to get
into the biology particularly of
microbes you start to understand
breastfeeding you start to understand
what Rajah just said right like the
choices that you make in your food and
the things that you eat and of course
then beyond your body beyond beyond your
children's bodies but to this planet
this idea that it's like awesome the
planet or like we need to save the plant
I mean you know a lot of scientists will
say the planets going to be just fine
it's
that's okay and so you know I think that
that'd that that sense and and Roger
said earlier the the dark matter the
dark Internet of our bodies but really
bacteria are the invisible internet of
everything and so we really try and you
know human health and Planetary health
or you know in some ways if we've done
our job and you know for in five years
it's like health is health yeah it's not
a dualistic bifurcated thing no we like
two other eyes which by the way we did
two bacteria for a really long time and
look where it got us yeah well are
something really compelling about how
when astronauts described the overview
effect of going and seeing earth they
feel a sense of ownership of commitment
or belonging that stewardship they they
need to take care of this it's it's
shared and if we can induce that same if
we can use microbes to induce that same
effect for human health I think it's a
system shift that would really go wide
and far one of our scientists said you
know it I wish we had a star chart for
our insights because if we could get
people to care about their bodies the
way they are obsessed and in all the
cosmos yeah what would they choose right
like what would you do every day if you
could just be like absolutely in awe of
what happens every day inside this this
body and then of course when you start
to think about its connection much like
biology is so spiritual 200 years ago
get no clue what's happening and now
it's all Google and no one cares that's
fascinating and it's true you know but I
think it it to bridge that gap it's
about storytelling right like if you can
harness the power of story to get people
interested in that and find a way in for
them to emotionally connect with it then
it opens the door to you know an
exploration that could be revolutionary
for everybody yeah I mean we we like we
like to say there's a few things that we
think need a good publicist science yeah
fiber bacteria uh-huh and so we we very
much try we
you know in the Nigerian needs rebranded
oh yeah yes but in the rebrand you need
a publicist although you know bacteria
bacteria is doing okay as probiotics are
the fastest-growing consumer health
category in the world so in some ways
they they are they're making a comeback
but we we think science has a huge
communication problem and you know
there's this notion that it's cold and
it's clinical and it's too complex and
therefore of course if you see an
Instagram with like Brazil getting
overturned yeah yeah so you know it's
you know look we as humans we don't
tolerate nuance very well and and I
think that you know to to our to our
detriment I think a lot of the time but
I think we we really believe that you
know in what and when you look at the
brand which is hard to articulate on a
podcast but when you look at the
aesthetic and and the words that we use
I mean so much of it we like to say
we're a version 30 Google Doc kind of
brand which means that we do obsess and
pour over not just the scientific
integrity of what we say but actually
how can someone hear this what what it
what are the words what is the image
that someone could actually hear this
and that we don't just you know also
create an echo chamber of people who are
already believing in this and therefore
we're just confirming what they already
believe but how do you actually shift
perspective which is really what that
overview effect is that astronauts
report and what we try and induce with
the interview effect but shifting
perspective is very very very
challenging one that we obsess over but
one that we do believe that this kind of
you know it like you said at the
beginning you know wait so I'm half
human well when you tell people they're
half human we think that you have a
little permission to hopefully give them
a new lens mm-hmm well the aesthetics of
what you guys have created our amazing
like the website in the Instagram
account I mean it's beautiful so even if
you're not interested in the microbiome
or you don't care about science like its
visually stunning and you're lured into
you know this kind of world that's new
and different for a lot of people and
scary and intimidating you know when you
think of science you do think of PubMed
and you think of you know really dry
people that are scared to talk doing a
cocktail party or something like that
and so it is about storytelling it
always think they're right
yeah the intentionality behind like how
you've branded this thing I think is
very cool and effective and at the same
time I think there's a populist interest
in science that I haven't seen in my
lifetime and a lot of it is being driven
by social media like when you see like I
always complain about you know the the
vitriol and the diet Wars on Twitter and
things like that but at least people are
talking about it you know they're
picking sides and they feel very strong
it's like they're arguing about science
people you know so you know if we if we
telescope out I think ultimately that's
a good thing to absolutely agree I think
we we just like what what I think that
what we try and induce is just this this
incessant life of questioning which is
really how you can ultimately and and
also this methodology of experimentation
right I think what happens though in
those arguments is that they are echo
chambers one of one of the things that I
I talk a lot about is how confirmation
bias is actually the greatest
communicable disease of our time it's
huge and so you're looking for
information that just confirms what you
already want to what you already believe
in what you want to believe about a
specific area the world nutrition diet
avocados fat cholesterol ketogenic diet
whatever whatever it is and so what's
missing and all of that those arguments
is any sense that you could change your
mind and one and the way the algorithms
work of social media is that it's not
the you know algorithms don't work to
serve you up the opposite of what you're
interested in or another opinion they
work to only continue to give you the
information and so if you if you're on
Apple news if you're on social when you
follow people you know you're training
it to say and the way that that we that
we create these technologies is that we
train it to say this is what I believe
and therefore give me more of what I
already believe and of course that is
antithetical to science and so that is
that the only thing I would say you are
right that of course yes I'm we
happy that people talk and care about
these things then the next layer is well
what what does it take to just ask
questions not change your mind entirely
but to be open to the idea that you're
at what you believe could iterate and
evolve and that's yeah there's something
inherently ironic about that scientific
you know cacophony because science is
about allegiance to truth in the most
universal sense without an emotional
attachment to outcome and these
dialogues are very emotional and they
are very results in confirmation bias
oriented and driven and look you have to
be somewhat empathic which is you know
science a science and any scientist will
admit this um although the perception of
science doesn't admit this which is that
science doesn't know everything and
there's the space between what science
knows and how people feel and of course
where people feel is incredibly
emotional and so one of the things that
and we're kind of working towards this
is you know how do you reconcile that
space and how do those two areas have a
dialogue that can be really productive
and empathic because I think that's
harder partially what has happened and
the reason a lot of that rhetoric exists
is because someone gets sick they go to
a Western doctor or somebody from like
let's say more traditional methodology
or training they don't get answers and
they end up in more of an Eastern or
alternative functional modality and they
feel that they get better answers and or
they get to a solution and so that and
then therefore this whole other you know
the original kind of methodology is
otherwise and you end up in an
interesting a really interesting cycle
and it's one that we see all the time we
have plenty of people who who are in our
community who have all kinds of
autoimmune disease and weren't getting
answers you know in one area and go of
course to to again typically more
Eastern like alternative and they and
they all of a sudden kind of feel heard
and listened to you and it's part I
think is yes the thing that really
connects they just because they don't
feel hurt by their Western medicine
practitioner so it's not that the
solution that's being given by the
Eastern practitioner
better it's just that that person feels
safe and like there's a two-way
communication happy medium is the
message
in thinking about this like thinking
about like the magic of the unseen and
talking about like space and you know
how we're fascinated with exploring you
know unchartered terrain and worlds and
you know how we still haven't like
mapped the ocean but there is this whole
universe in the microbiome that like you
said 2006 is when science really started
taking this seriously for the very first
time like we're not even out of the
starting gate and trying to understand
what's happening here and there is a
spirituality to it I mean the vastness
of it yes is both intimidating but also
you know fantastical and beautiful yeah
and actually the what you said about
both sides hearing each other is is one
of the reasons you know there's never
been an area of science like microbiome
science that's kind of progressed at the
velocity that microbiome science in
really traditional science academia
leading research institutions around the
world has that's been met with consumer
awareness and and spending and kind of
over indexing of interest in their in
their own lives and in their own health
and that has all me I always say Raj and
I always heard about there's like you
you know we sequenced the human genome
you go to Whole Foods and you what you
can't buy anything for your genome right
you know you sequence the human
microbiome and you have the fast
consumer you know you have the fastest
growing you know consumer health
category in the world in the form of
probiotics and of course if you start
adding in on all things related to gut
health and now of course skincare and
oral - and other categories and so what
one of my hypothesis or one of the the
confounding factors that I I think is
leading to and has Lana has kind of
gotten us here is because Eastern
modalities have talked about the gut for
so long and the rise of those modalities
and of course the over-indexing of kind
of interest in though in those areas
combined with the fact that very
mainstream science and
and now more increasingly more
traditional doctors are starting to kind
of it's actually it's one of the first
areas where they actually kind of have
level most like a Switzerland like they
actually meet in the middle and there's
some agreement and of course Eastern you
know people from more Eastern alternate
functional practices will say well we've
known this for thousands of years and
then of course the scientists or the
more traditional medical doctors yeah
but you didn't know it was in it you
don't know what to do with it you know
you weren't looking at like microbes to
you know change the reuptake of
cholesterol into the body but so I so I
think it's interesting because it's all
of a sudden created like kind of it very
there's really never been an area where
they come at it from both sides and
there's like this kind of in the Venn
diagram of kind of east and west that
kind of sits right in the middle in
terms of now having a place to kind of
speak to where there's overlap it's this
science making its way into medical
school curriculum I mean they teach
gastroenterology right but that's I wish
nutrition would know there's it hasn't
certainly not introductory curriculums
or during medical school but now in some
specializations what's very unique is
that more research-oriented doctors or
ones that go into publishing or teaching
are finding an area like a blue sky
ahead so immunologists
gastroenterologist neurologists all
these different disciplines are storming
yet because the Galant colleges and our
own colleges yeah
sits at the center of a lot of these
biological processes and so it's it's
very attractive it's it's a it's a hot
new field in science but more academic
science than in you know medical
practice as an athlete I'm always
interested in performance so what is the
relationship between gut health the
quality of your microbiome and athletic
performance yes so a good friend of mine
came out of the church lab at Harvard
that's exclusively looking at organisms
that are found in the gut of elite
athletes that are involved in breaking
down lactate for muscle recovery for
performance in recovery and at this
point they he's sequence marathon
runners profession NBA players and
there's this common funky
that's conserved which might give even
if it's a 2% edge might give athletes a
little bit of an edge there's another
study that we've actually it was a small
study but it was a crossover trial so
there's very powerfully designed showing
that specific probiotic consumption
actually when you max out muscles delay
increases the speed by which you regain
function or full extension of those
muscles again by modulating the cytokine
profiles in the body so those are
inflamed inflammatory and Flemmi zone
responds profiles and then of course
there's the barrier integrity there's a
whole thesis around exercise rips up
your gut barrier there's ways where your
microbiome you could want it to be more
efficient for energy utilization so it's
oftentimes a phenomenon that you see why
elite athletes when they stop training
become really fat because now they have
now they have developed a microbiome
which is very efficient at an additional
extra energy utilization but they don't
have the same energy expenditure anymore
well also they keep eating the way
there's done that yeah
what about increasing the body's ability
to recover more expeditiously as a
result of exercise induced stress yeah
small small studies but they're pretty
convincing showing that there's about a
15 to 20 percent increase in recovery
time which you know when you are at that
elite level can make a really big
difference and so are these gut flora
endemic to these athletes or are there
things that somebody who's listening who
you know can do to you know move their
gut biome in that direction yep so the
two strains that I probiotic strains
that I mentioned we acquired so there
are strains that are in our male
formulation for increase in recovery
time in response to max outt strength
and changing the cytokine profiles the
Harvard strains which are found in
marathon runners there's some early
early work that's happening but the
regulatory process for getting those
into humans is going to take quite a bit
of some time and so those aren't
available but conceivably you could
maybe the Amish will start a black
market the Amish way you could you could
acquire something yeah I mean I think at
this point we should just do an Amish we
should buy we should just all become
become Amish or is it like great we'll
sequence your gut before adopting an
Amish lifestyle for six months and then
it'll sequence it afterwards and we'll
publish the results
that's an interesting study and if you
want to grab some friends to increase
our statistical power yeah but it's
still an N of one no I'll go live in the
Amish community we have to move do I
hear a speech thanks coming on I think
that is a binding offer think about that
well so you have these right now you
guys have these you have two products
basically you have a mail daily and a
female daily yes in that you call it a
symbiotic which basically means it's a
combination of probiotic and prebiotic
yeah so I want to give you the
opportunity to explain you know more
about the product itself but this is
just really this is the beginning of a
whole like when we met the other day you
were telling me about all these
interesting things that you're
developing right now exactly you wanna
yeah this is this is where we started
because they're our whole thesis was to
build a strain bank strain specific bank
on that has defined effects in the body
and so there's over 20 published all
available on PubMed randomized
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
on these strains there's a number of
categories from those five markers of
digestion to down regulating the
inflammatory response in the gut to
improving oxidative profiles related to
oxidative stress to dampening it to
mitigating gut barrier permeability so
reverse preventing the transfer or the
crossing of microbial endotoxins into
serum circulation into the bloodstream
there's the exercise cocktails at our
male formulation but not in the female
formulation because the trial was only
done on male
on men so we're very specific about
aligning the clinical work to the
products and in our female formulation
we have an additional cocktail of
strains which downregulated the
inflammatory response at the surface of
the skin so the score add score which is
a marker of disruptions in the skin
related to dryness scabbing dermatitis
eczema psoriasis and dermatological
health is is uniquely found in the in
the female population so in a female
product and so really we took an
approach for this flagship product of
you know it's over engineered it has in
some instances it has three or four
strains of the same species there's not
not a single product on the market that
has that and all with this with
mechanistic or human efficacy data
supporting it and so I think that's a
core differentiator for this product
I mean oftentimes you'll see most people
take probiotics if you ask them well why
do you take a probiotic it's because
they have digestive issues or because
they think that it would be good for
them and so both would benefit from this
collection of strains because the
specificity of these strains are
designed for the for that type of an
individual and how is it distinct from
say you know VSL 3 yea VSL 3 is an 8
species probiotic and the majority of
their well barring the most recent
lawsuit about how all the VSL 3
commercially is a departure from the
original clinically tested formulation
it's a 8 species high load product where
most of the efficacy data is on things
like pouch itis or i think they have a
couple ulcerative colitis but it's
really like looking at thanks using a
brute force approach with high high
levels of generic species to over to
have to have some sort of believed
effect but all their tests is on our on
disease models right so they don't have
any reason I mean I haven't seen any
barrier integrity or any functional
biophysical measurements for in terms of
digestive function that have been that
have been conducted by by that product
so but to their credit it is one of the
it is the only product of it it is one
of the few products that yeah I mean
that's
that's always come up we're on to
Patrick talks it's sort of like the one
that you know if you want to get like oh
this is the kind like that's the name
that recurrent you know I was recurring
so that's why I wanted to yeah and a lot
of you know a lot of this too in terms
of this first product was also to really
also you know start to tell this
narrative that microbes are not you know
probiotics aren't just like oh I have
some weird digestion or I just took
antibiotics I'll just take a probiotic
that that that microbes actually can
have and in part benefits on on various
organ systems of the body and that was
that was part of the of course the the
most important thing being that it can
really make an impact in people's health
of course we hear this every day from
our community but and beyond that to
really start to move the narrative away
from just being like oh I have bad
digestion and can you talk a little bit
about some of the things you're you're
working on absolutely depends on this is
going to come out well it could be a
while so there they are worthy of I
think that each of the big announcements
should be have have their own we could
we could have really kind of in-depth on
it a moment on each one of them but as
we kind of started you know we're not
just interested in in in supplementation
or on cursory or are not
life-threatening conditions like
digestion but really you know food
ingredients so ways in which replacing
some of the biggest aggressors in our
food supply with functional beneficial
prebiotic fibrous compounds could
improve human health and so very soon
we'll be able to make a big announcement
around there also I would say you know
particularly when you look at areas like
allergies for example um we're working
on a line of probiotics that will be
very targeted and very clear
applications of clinical work that you
know in some cases coming out of five
hundred persons with a trial that just
concluded on a 600 person cohort I mean
and these are self-funded trials that
you guys are some of them are in
partnership some of them are self so so
this trial that I mentioned it's
with academic 11 different sites and
academic collaborators
that were because that the data was so
compelling enough it took over a year to
enroll all the people for to measure
allergic response and so this was
conducted in northern Italy where there
was a big demand from the the medical
centers themselves to conduct and
organize and design and fund and develop
the trial and so thus these strains were
just what we're offered up as the
intervention how many scientists do you
guys currently have on staff or that
your many of the scientists in our that
that we work with actually directly
particularly with their academic labs
actually to be maintaining their
academic standing you know aren't aren't
full-time employees with us but actually
more collaborators mostly because we
work to keep them exactly mostly because
we need to work with their labs
depending on the time we have probably
over 20 now and if you include some of
our more recent division or newer
divisions over 30 mm-hmm and where do
you do the manufacturing and the
packaging and all of that yes so I can
speak for the manufacturing so bacteria
are very fragile and some of our strains
are very very picky anaerobes so they
they hate oxygen they really hate oxygen
so for those types of processes you need
to use a lot of like a nitrogen flush or
ways to keep oxygen out from the entire
fermentation development process and so
actually strangely enough when you think
of fermentation you probably think of
French cheese but as a result of that
cultural have not so deeply steeped in
their culture that have some of the
largest scale-up facilities by
fermentation facilities in the world so
the majority of all of our fermentation
happens in southern France and northern
Italy
mmm with a little bit in Japan and then
some of it happens here in the States
now and the strains come from all all
over and then are some of our packaging
we've we've scoured the world looking
for sustainable options we work with
some really interesting companies one we
grow some of our our trays from mycelium
and so it's actually compacted
agricultural waste that then grows
on skin so we use that in place of other
kind of less sustainable options for for
how we pack our product a corn foam
which I was insulating property but also
you can eat it or just dissolve it in
water and then all of our labels and all
of our labels and all of our pouches are
are compostable yeah
and actually and actually we only ship
one the system itself particularly for
this first product it
we only ship a jar once and then every
step so come on through just get this
some this pouch that's compostable that
you refill your jar right yeah it's
really cool you have this beautiful
glass jar and then the refill packaging
recyclable and the initiative of
compostable and I love that about it
like how you've put like sustainability
at the forefront and and and creating
story around like those materials
themselves like literally the packing
material isn't mycelium that's like
crazy which is really cool but look I'd
be remiss if I didn't you know ask you
you know how you think about
transparency in a post Elizabeth Holmes
Thera knows world right like you've done
a great job of you know storytelling
around what you're doing and in creating
these initiatives and these products but
you know there is like I you know I
watched a documentary I listened to the
six-part podcast definitely obsessed
with Elizabeth Holmes and it's like I
think it's incumbent upon founders
anybody who's running a company to
prioritize transparency in a new and
honest way to kind of overcome that was
like I just feel a resistance like well
what do I know you know how do I know
that this is real or true or you know
these guys tell a great story but like I
don't know what's inside of any of this
and it's not regulated and how can you
film that you know consumer trust in
what you're doing yeah so the the first
part that I think I'm also fascinated by
the Elizabeth Holmes story I think that
it was the perfect in some ways all of
her quirks are so unoriginal it's like
they're borrowed from different quirky
icons that she had that it's just the
note blinking I think the L boy it's
like watching a car crash in crime
we read of Li slow motion and yeah you
know some deep thinkers and certainly
founders are a little awkward and it's I
could I could have said you could seem
not coming from the very beginning and
certainly I think it's a cautionary tale
for a lot of companies that are
leveraging the magic of technology to
give solutions that science has never
been able to acquire before I think it's
a very important cautionary tale and I
think that I'm very grateful that that
has happened to encourage people to
publish don't hide behind a cloak of
transparency certainly if you want to
that's fine because trade secrets also
we recognize are in some instances
important but not but if you're selling
products for humans
then you shouldn't hide behind that
cloak anymore so in many ways science
the the recipe of the Thera gnosis of
the world are hide behind a magical
technology don't publish or disclose it
to the world raise money and balloon to
a massive valuation stay private as long
as you can and don't engage academia or
the system of peer review or Wall Street
your hack your porn super powerful
people instead of scientists by the way
regulators instead of scientists I mean
it's the it's a it's the hallmark of
close-up magic I don't you know anything
about magic but it's it is actually what
close-up magicians or the best that I
think what we can't you know the the
nice thing about peer review and the
methodology and the the way that science
has evolved is that it has put
self-regulation in place which is that
you can't publish these things and in
fact most companies say that they do
studies and then they don't publish on
where they put them on their website but
they're not published anywhere that's a
respected peer-reviewed journal and I
think that that is certainly one area
where we really try to and then of
course or where we do but but I think
where a lot of companies kind of don't
even though they use the word science
pretty pretty liberally I think both in
marketing and certainly the way they
talk about their company I think the
other aspect you know is that in the
translation of it I think we're I think
there are many and I'm sure you and I
both know many people who have built
pretty substantial direct-to-consumer
supplement companies
there are many many tactics that we
could be employing that we don't and I
think that's just the Wild West of yeah
and you know in an increasingly you know
Facebook and and various you know
platforms have certainly started to at
least really try to crack down a little
bit on that the FTC has started to send
letters to specific influencers
particularly for Instagram influencers
who aren't using the appropriate
methodology is around like how you
promote her or are transparent with your
audience around whether something is an
ad and or whether or not your experience
is not a generalized experience that
somewhat everybody has of the product
one of the areas I think in some ways
it's not just what we do and of course
we put our testing on on the website we
put the studies on the website we we
will do more and more as we move you
know we're very early so of course as we
move through our pipeline will continue
to increase the the number of things
that we can disclose when they're ready
enough obviously when we're ready to
publish of course the the other way of
looking at it is what we don't do and so
a lot of it are the tactics like for
example one of the things we've really
tried to reconcile is that we get
testimonials every single day from
people saying that basically you've
saved their life or change their life or
they can't live without your product and
they make all kinds of claims and say
and of course it's it's flattering and
and you are very you're happy that
you've created something that has made
an impact particularly with people who
have suffered for a long time very often
with some sort of autoimmune conditions
but what we don't do is take quotes from
those and then just slap them all over
ads and or long-form landing pages and
then try and get people to buy it and
believe that that would have the same
impact for them so one of the things
that we're working on two things were
working on one is for affiliate
marketers so we're working on an
educational program that you actually
cannot get your affiliate links until
you go through a course with us that is
actually not very minimally about our
product but actually more about the
underlying science about the microbiome
about you know actually even the FTC
regulation before you're actually able
to even access those links to be able to
work with us
in any kind of performance marketing way
so that's kind of one one at least first
expression of it and then the next is
starting to think about how could we use
people's experiences of our product in a
way that is Integris that is very clear
when the science does not support what
they are saying but does allow community
to build and to share with each other in
a way that we don't want to necessarily
stand in the way of people who can share
because we do see that there are some
reasons why people who have specific
conditions or have experiences want to
connect one another the question is how
can we do that integrally yet yet also
steward what we're talking about and
with it with regards to transparency
what's the long-term view here like
what's the utopian you know being on
universe yeah I guess right and have
amazing health but paint the picture of
you know the world you want to see and
you know the mission that you're aiming
for so I think it's understated the
different if the importance of microbes
for a lot of areas of the human body and
what we've just talked on this podcast
is just scratching the surface I think
that you can design life in a way that's
very microbial eccentric or that's
microbially considerate and that you can
I don't want to say prevent or treat
conditions except for the areas where
we're playing by the rules and engaging
with the FDA to make claims to show that
we could prevent or treat conditions you
know but there's there's kind of a
future where we look at our we look at
our bodies we look at the earth we
modulate this microbial community and we
can have a dramatic and profound and
measurable impact on human health in a
way that I think is is is wholly
different or has been lost
from the way that we've designed our
societies today and so it's it's along
the lines of get dirty but a little bit
more scientifically mmm-hmm I'd say it's
it really is truly a shift perspective I
we totally undo and to
live and almost this like Mike these
micro moments of our lives
in a way that fundamentally like feels
like you were given new eyes like we
always say we wish it kind of have like
Minority Report coggle is where you know
for you know moms are like don't touch
that that's dirty you know don't put
your hands on that don't eat that that
was on the floor you know there's so
many moments that you don't even realize
that have been kind of embedded in in
our lives and our wiring around like
what
so whether something is good or not good
for you and in the in the in the
instance where we actually interrupt
some of that wiring and rewire in a way
that makes us conscious of many of the
things we basically spoke about today I
mean I think that's where we win and
that's regardless of whether someone
buys our products or not because you
know the truth is you can make huge
impact in your life just by changing
things like nutrition or some of the
other areas and so it is that it's that
perspective shift I think that to me is
where we will we will have one in in
though in the sense that you you undo
many of the things you help to be true
which which I think would benefit our
planet also and we start to look through
that lens because we'll make decisions
from that lens we'll sit around
boardrooms and tables for marketing
campaigns and packaging conversations
and and and you'll say well what is the
most sustainable from a more holistic
sense that includes thinking about
microbes not thinks about how you you
know eradicate them right I like that I
think that's a good place to land this
plane for people that are listening that
want to learn more go to see calm and
what's cool about the website is you got
time I mean you can read forever you got
so much information up there so it
really is a great place to start to
expand your your horizon your knowledge
base on on gut health in the microbiome
so I would start there check out their
product and let's leave people with you
know we kind of alluded to it a couple
of minutes ago but you know a couple
things that they can like if somebody's
listening to this and and this is all
brand new to them like what are some
simple things you know besides just not
using soap so much that people
can develop and work into their own
daily routines that can enhance their
microbiome health I would say one of the
things I find that in particularly
people who are already trying to eat
healthy they end up getting into like a
routine or rhythm so that they eat the
saint's like a lot of the same things
every day and to kind of rewire that a
little up to at least thirty different
plants fruits and vegetables each week
it's like one very easy diversity of
plants be the first one I would say we
can go back and forth okay
so I'll give a provocative one which is
be mindful of sexual intercourse
unprotected with a new partner because
that can have person that wall we have a
whole research track focused on it and
there's very few native vaginal
communities which can there is a
disruption let's say or I shouldn't be
done flippantly I should say that's it
for other wise words yeah what something
like you just you know walk through your
day and you see people doing something
and you're like why are they doing that
don't they know I mean I mean the the
one of the more obvious ones is just how
much I see that people still use like
all the sanitizers which I'm I'm I kind
of thinking maybe we live a little bit
in a bubble in in LA but I kind of
didn't realize how much that was how
pervasive those things are everywhere
yep I think liquids you're in a hospital
that's great that liquid sugar and the
in liquids sugar in an unbound
carbohydrate form which is used as a
sweetener in liquid beverages and even
healthy ones a lot of things at Whole
Foods yeah that are marketed as healthy
have really high sugar content - yeah my
second thought and go out in nature and
roll around in the dirt get a dog right
get a dog
you didn't bring your dog today what's
your dog's name it's you know Luke and
Sasha
our wild dogs from northern Russia
uh-huh yeah they're really cool as your
broth they have probably a good makeup
right next time Thanks
thanks you guys so see calm at seed on
Instagram those two best places to
direct people to go check out their
stuff read up thank you so much
talking to you let's talk let's talk
more you don't want to come back okay
I'd love to thank you
peace peace plants microbiome
[Music]